[Musik]
ich hätte ihn gerne erfreulichere
nachrichten kurz vor den
weihnachtsfeiertagen mitgeteilt diese
pandemie strengt uns alle an wir alle
sind nur mit der pandemie müde
das hilft aber nichts wir müssen
abermals zusammen stehen und auch in
vielen fällen eben distanz halten war
für den heutigen tag und für die jetzige
situation
sind angemessene maßnahmen entschieden
worden jetzt geht es darum die auch
entsprechend umzusetzen
und es geht wie gesagt bei allem was wir
tun schon auch unverhältnismäßigkeit
soweit die stimme nach dem bund länder
gipfel dessen ergebnisse nun
gewissermaßen auf dem gabentisch liegen
kurz vor weihnachten und die wir in
diesem zdf spezial analysieren wollen
guten abend ihnen allen und herzlich
willkommen dazu ja zweieinhalb stunden
haben bundeskanzler scholz und die 16
ministerpräsidenten und präsidentinnen
in einer video konferenz beraten das ist
eine altbekannte runde und doch eine
entscheidende heute denn mitten in der
vierten welle kündigt sich bereits die
fünfte an zu verdanken einer variante
namens omikron die um ein vielfaches
ansteckender ist und vor der selbst
doppelt geimpfte nicht gefeit sind der
neue expertenrat der bundesregierung hat
ja daher schon am sonntag unter anderem
kontakt beschränkungen auch für geimpfte
empfohlen und die werden nach dem
heutigen und länder beschloss auch
kommen demnach dürfen sich geimpfte und
genesene mit maximal zehn personen
privat treffen egal ob draußen oder
drinnen kinder unter 14 jahren werden
nicht mitgerechnet bei ungeimpften ist
es der eigene haushalt plus maximal zwei
personen
überregionale großveranstaltungen wie
bundesliga spiele sollen zunächst ohne
zuschauer ausgetragen werden und clubs
sowie diskotheken werden geschlossen und
dazu begrüße ich die ministerpräsidentin
von rheinland pfalz guten abend frau
dreyer
guten abend herr pläne
gehen sie denn heute abend mit dem
gefühl in diesen abend ja wir haben
alles menschenmögliche
getan und beschlossen um die gesundheit
der menschen zu schützen
wir haben auf jeden fall beschlossen
dass der neue expertenrat uns empfohlen
hat und viel mehr kann politik ja auch
nicht leisten ich glaube dass wir uns
sehr gut vorbereiten mit erhöhten
boostern mit der sicherstellung dass
unsere kritische infrastruktur auch eine
welle von omikron verkraften wird und
wir sind wirklich auch dabei mit den
kontakt beschränkungen dass man den
menschen wirklich noch mal deutlich
sagen es ist gut wenn kontakte
beschränkt werden begrenzt werden wir
können uns alle schützen
das robert koch-institut geht ja heute
noch einen schritt weiter empfiehlt
maximale kontakt und reisebeschränkungen
noch vor den feiertagen den folgen sie
nun nicht sind sie nun auch sauer auf
laute lothar wieler wie scholz und
lauterbach oder macht es sie
nachdenklich dass die politik hinter
wissenschaftliche expertise zurück
bleibt
nein ich verwahre mich sogar ein
bisschen davor wenn wir haben einen
expertenrat mit 19 hoch profilierten
wissenschaftlern und
wissenschaftlerinnen
dazu gehört auch ávila vom rk ii und das
gutachten oder die erste stellungnahme
dieses expertenrates ist jetzt gerade
mal zwei oder drei tage alt die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hat
unbegehbar danach wirklich auch die
tagung aufgenommen wir haben heute den
vorsitzenden des expertenrates auch in
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz noch
einmal gehört und das was diese
expertenrat uns empfohlen hat das werden
wir genau befolgen und das ist
tatsächlich auch das was wir wollten
nämlich dass es ein interdisziplinär
zusammengesetztes gremium gibt das gibt
es jetzt es gibt uns einen rad und wir
werden diesen rat auch befolgen und zwar
sehr konsequent
genau dieser expertenrat hatte ja auch
davor gewarnt dass durch abby konnte die
kritische infrastruktur bedroht sein
könnte lahmgelegt durch zehntausende
erkrankter mitarbeiter
wie gut sind dann nach der heutigen
runde die bundesländer für diesen
ernstfall gerüstet
der bund- länder- krisenstab unter
anleitung von general breuer hat ja
bereits getagt dort ist dann beschlossen
worden dass alle szenarien machen bei 10
20 und 30 prozent ausfall des personals
genau das bereiten wir auch auf
landesebene vor gerade jetzt findet eine
schaltkonferenz mit unseren kommunen
statt also wir sind wirklich im doing
man so schön denn wir wollen
sicherstellen dass die kritische
infrastruktur einer möglichen welle
durch micon wirklich dann auch gut
gewappnet gegenübersteht aus dem
gesundheitswesen kommt daher die
forderung die quarantäne regeln für
pflegekräfte für ärzte und sanitäter zu
ändern infizierte mit einem milden
verlauf
so heißt es müssten ja nicht zwingen 14
tage lang ausfallen ist es für sie
verhandlungsfähig
unbedingt auch das ist in der prüfung
wenn ich den bundesgesundheitsminister
heute richtig verstanden habe da wird im
moment überprüft ob die absonderung
verordnung die diese quarantäne
regelungen vorsieht tatsächlich neu
erlassen wird und das halte ich auch für
dringend notwendig dort wo es
verantwortbar ist dass man tatsächlich
dann menschen diese möglichkeit der
verkürzung der quarantäne gibt
beratungsbedarf gibt es noch und am 17
januar wollen bund und länder zu ihrer
nächsten runde zusammenkommen um über
die korona lage zu beraten malu dreyer
danke für das gespräch
ich danke ihnen und
das haben wir kurz vor der sendung
aufgezeichnet ja dass bund länder
treffen ist vorbei entscheidungen sind
gefallen aber kaum verkündet steht deren
haltbarkeit doch in frage müssen die
beschlossenen maßnahmen angesichts
galoppierender fallzahlen womöglich
schon zu jahresbeginn
nachgeschärft werden aus ersten
modellrechnungen geht hervor dass sich
omikron drei bis viermal schneller
verbreitet als bisherige varianten die
weltgesundheitsorganisation leitet auch
aus dieser erkenntnis heute eine
dringende warnung abreisen und größere
weihnachtsfeiern sollten unbedingt
abgesagt werden und auch das robert koch
institut hat seine gefahren einschätzung
durch omikron angepasst
die gefährdung für die bevölkerung in
deutschland wird als sehr hoch
eingeschätzt verkündet das robert koch
institut im hinblick auf die omikron
variante gestern das rk ii trifft seine
bewertung auf grundlage aktueller auch
internationaler daten zu übertragbarkeit
schwere profil der krankheitsverläufe
und der ressourcen belastung des
gesundheitswesens
eingeordnet wird das risiko in vier
verschiedene stufen von gering über
moderat und hoch bis sehr hoch
in der erka risikobewertung wird auch
noch mal in verschiedene untergruppen
unterschieden so sei das risiko für
ungeimpfte sehr hoch für zweifach
geimpfte hoch und für menschen die schon
den booster stich bekommen haben noch
moderat wie einfach omikron auch bei
doppelt geimpften zu infektionen führen
kann zeigt ein ausbruch in norwegen der
vor wochen schon aufschreckte und zudem
jetzt genauere daten vorliegen nach
einer weihnachtsfeier in oslo waren fast
drei viertel der über 100 teilnehmenden
mit omikron infiziert
91 prozent davon symptomatisch 96
prozent der betroffenen waren
vollständig geimpft niemand war jedoch
gemustert die dritte impfung gilt als
notwendig um auch besser vor einer
ansteckung mit der neuen virus variante
zu schützen in deutschland wird derzeit
genau deshalb eine massive booster
impfkampagne gefahren wie schlägt sich
das in den zahlen nieder mindestens
einmal die impft sind mit stand heute
morgen 73,5 prozent eine vollständige
grundimmunisierung erhalten haben 70,4
prozent gebucht sind inzwischen schon
32,6 prozent
ja soweit die statistik und welche
schlüsse die wissenschaft daraus zieht
darüber wollen wir mit dem biologen
henrik strikt sprechen mitglied im neuen
expertenrat der bundesregierung guten
abend nach bonn einen schönen guten
abend herr professor strikt wenn sie
sich die beschlüsse der bund länder
runter anschauen und die sind gerade mal
eine halbe stunde alte fühlen sie sich
als teil des expertenrats dann gehört
und verstanden
ja ich denke schon also wir sind ja in
einer situation in der wir auf der einen
seite ein stagnierender fallzahlen
seelen auf der anderen seite ab einen
deutlichen und bisher noch nicht
wahrnehmbaren anstieg der omicron fälle
wir haben in anderen ländern wie in
dänemark oder norwegen ja mitbekommen
was passiert wenn man omikron nicht
ernst nimmt da es dort zu einer
explosionsartigen ausbreitung der
infektion gekommen ist wir haben in
deutschland bereits aber weitreichende
maßnahmen sowieso gehabt und daher haben
wir empfohlen dass diese welle ernst zu
nehmen ist dass er die abbremsen sollten
und dass er die omikron vorsichtig
begegnen dafür sind die beschlüsse der
mpk erst mal ein guter weg aber man kann
ja bei einem rapiden anstieg vor allem
auf den intensivstationen dann auch sehr
schnell und zielgerichtet weiter nach
riskieren aber weihnachten ist jetzt
zunächst einmal ausgeklammert die
kontakt beschränkungen auch für geimpfte
sollen erst ab ende dezember gelten ist
das wirklich vernünftig
wir sind ja in der situation noch dass
wir reagieren können weiß wir einen zu
schnellen anstieg haben werden und daher
finde ich es auch gerechtfertigt dass
wir im moment im vergleich zu den wochen
davor wirklich und fallende zahl zahlen
gehabt haben sehe ich es auch
gerechtfertigt dass man weihnachten
hiervon noch ausklammert die politiker
verweisen der gerne auf bestehende
regeln diese schon beschlossen haben
dazu gehört die 2g 3g test pflichten
hygienevorschriften aber zeigt die
weihnachtsfeier von oslo von der gerade
im beitrag die rede war nicht dass diese
maßnahmen bei omikron ja im grunde
genommen wirkungslos sind
ja nee eigentlich der fall in oslo zeigt
uns eindrücklich das gelesene ungeimpfte
auch zum infektionsgeschehen beitragen
können und wirklich jeder noch teil der
pandemie ist aber der ausbruch zeigt
dass ihr keine schweren verläufe dadurch
haben wir haben viele symptomatische
infektion aber soweit ich weiß ist
bisher keiner der infizierten musste im
krankenhaus behandelt werden anders sehe
das aus wäre das ein ausbruch unter
ungeimpften und daher auch wenn wir die
infektion nicht vermeiden können haben
wir hier die möglichkeit immer noch die
zwei durch zweig zum beispiel die welle
in den krankenhäusern abzudämpfen nun
stehen hier die weihnachtsfeiertage an
familien wollen gemeinsam feiern
großeltern wollen ihre enkelkinder sehen
und auch umarmen die letzte frage mit
der bitte um eine kürzere antworte was
tun aus geologischer sicht wieder wie im
letzten jahr darauf verzichten
naja ich schauen sie wir sind doch
eigentlich in einer besseren situation
wir haben impfstoffe wenn man geimpft
oder genesen ist und vor allem wenn man
sich gestern lässt das ist auch ein
dringender aufruf
dann kann man auch genauso auch
weiterhin weihnachten feiern am besten
sich vorher testen lassen oder
hochfrequenten und vor allem auch
vielleicht um vor quarantine gehen wenn
man sich dollar sorgen macht das werden
viele menschen in diesem lande gerne
hören professor strich danke und großer
nachbarn sehr gerne
wir werden die heutigen entscheidungen
der politik die wirtschaft belasten
pauschal ist die frage wohl nicht zu
beantworten denn welche zugangsregeln
gelten ob etwa hotels oder restaurants
ganz schließen müssen hängt von der
pandemischen lage in den bundesländern
ab und die ist ja doch recht
unterschiedlich im gleichnis gardiner
land hatten sie angesichts sinkender
zahlen zuletzt noch auf eine
reibungslose wintersaison gehofft aber
dieses kleine licht der hoffnung dass
erlischt langsam
noch sind gäste da doch das wird sich
auch im hotel lag in ramsau schnell
ändern denn viele winterurlauber haben
bereits ihre reise in das
berchtesgadener land storniert ja man
großen silvesterball geplant allerdings
schon halber kraft weil wir sehr viele
stornierungen schon hatten bis jetzt
weihnachten und silvester und ich
befürchte dass es dazu kommen wird wenn
schon privaten bereich auf zehn personen
eingeschenkt wird dass wir hier im hotel
auch noch einschränkungen erleben werden
im landkreis berchtesgaden spüren die
gastgeber das zögerliche
buchungsverhalten ein grund sind die
steigende zahl der an omikron
infizierten ein anderer liegt ein paar
wochen zurück als der landkreis im
herbst wegen sehr hoher inzidenz wieder
einen lock down verkraften musste alles
war zu aktuell red auch noch das rkw von
unnötigen reisen ab doch die kühlräume
dieses hotel sind randvoll ware die
während der weihnachtszeit normalerweise
schnell verarbeitet wird doch was ist in
diesen zeiten schon normal
zwei millionen euro hat der hotelier in
seinem betrieb investiert die küche hat
nun eine top lüftungsanlage die zimmer
wurden mit hochwertigen betten
ausgestattet dazu kommen 90 mitarbeiter
die bezahlt werden müssen doch immer
wieder gibt es neue meldungen aus berlin
ich würde mir mehr verlässlichkeit
wünschen
zuverlässigkeit dahingehend dass man
nicht so kurzfristig diese
entscheidungen trifft ein paar kilometer
weiter in bischofswiesen steht dieses
nagelneue hotel des tourismus chefs
bartl wimmer es ist winter hochsaison
doch auch in seinem hotel werden an
weihnachten viele zimmer leer stehen
das in den letzten zwei drei wochen die
anzahl der studierenden deutlich höher
war als die der buchungen in den
bayrischen wintersportorten testen viele
gastgeber ihr personal jeden tag sie
stehen für die hochsaison bereit doch
noch fehlen die gäste
die omikron welle wird einer
naturkatastrophe ändern hat die
schweizer virologin isabella eckerle
kürzlich gesagt das klingt dramatisch
und das wird auch dramatisch wenn es
jetzt nicht gelingt der variante den
stecker zu ziehen ob das gelingt hängt
von den heutigen beschlüssen ab und
davon ob eine ko runde der erschöpfte
bevölkerung mitzieht das war unser zdf
spezial danke für ihr interesse und noch
einen schönen abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]